We've talked about how frameworks
provide templating, URL management and
event handling to control an app's data.
These are the V and the C in MVC speak,
but where is the data or the M in MVC?
How is the data being
managed by the client?
Does it live on the client?
And what happens with the data
when we stop using it?
If we take another look
at the to do NVC site,
we'll see that it doesn't
start with any data.
This is a common scenario.
The app starts out empty waiting for
the user to provide the data.
Then when data is added
more features appear.
Now that we have our data, what happens
to it when we're done with the site.
To do NVC used local storage to
save the user provide the data.
This, however, is not permanent,
and is only saved on this computer.
If I open up the developer tools,
go to the resources tab, and
open up local storage,
you can see the tasks I entered.
If I delete these entries and
refresh the page,
you'll see that the tasks are gone.
Browsers can make use of web storage,
like local storage or index DB for
temporary storage.
But typically, a framework will send
their data off to a server to be saved.
Then, when they need that data,
they'll just fetch it from the server.
For example, firebase is a platform
that let's you store and retrieve data.
It has a rest server, and can easily be
integrated with a front end framework.